réforme des retraites aussi Elisabeth
borne reçoit à Matignon demain les
parties et les groupes parlementaires la
France insoumise et les communistes ont
décidé de ne pas s'y rendre les taux
pouvoirs depuis un an et maintenant se
pose la question de savoir quel genre de
programme elle va faire tout ça est une
autre riz participons pas est-ce que si
on vient vous voir
on vous mettiez sur la table la réforme
des retraites et donc la pause le non
promulgation la suspension etc non dans
les rues de Tel-Aviv des milliers de
manifestants pour la 13ème semaine
consécutive une pression constante qui a
fait reculer la coalition d'extrême
droite au pouvoir elle a annoncé une
pause dans son projet décrié de réformes
de la justice et un rouleau compresseur
incontestable
d'une partie extrêmement
entendu ces derniers jours sur les ondes
de l'extrême gauche qui attaque les
policiers et les gendarmes en dessous de
la ceinture qui leur tirent dans le dos
les macronistes sont déclinants et ils
ont pensé que puisqu'il n'avait aucun
projet de société ils ont donc un projet
Lordon pour ça il faut qu'ils inventent
des diables le diable en l'occurrence
c'est moi et les insoumis et la nuit
vous êtes en train de dire que j'ai
grave Darmanin vous diabolise absolument
celles et ceux qui entretiennent
l'ambiguïté sont au gouvernement et
passent leur journée expliquer qu'on
serait ambigu sur le sujet mais nous ne
le sommes pas par contre leur rhétorique
clé elle est à descend il en conscience
il choisisse de nous présenter comme des
gens qui sommes violents qui
représentaient un risque terroriste
parce qu'il pense que de cette manière
sa candidature à l'Élysée pourra
surplomber tout le parti de l'or c'est
ça
que je pense c'est ce que je vois c'est
pas un éditeuriste un peu musclé qui dit
ça c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte où
on en est arrivé dans ce pays c'est très
grave et c'est dangereux ça va mal se
terminer Monsieur Mélenchon c'est un
cynique il n'a pas pu être
responsabilité politique malgré ses
plusieurs essais Monsieur Mélenchon il a
compris que l'extrême gauche était
extrêmement minoritaire dans les urnes
et dans l'esprit des Français Gérald de
Darmanin n'arrivera pas à faire croire
aux Français qu'il est l'homme de
l'ordre ce gouvernement a laissé
s'installer le chaos dans notre société
il a laissé par cynisme politique les
milices d'ultra-go je vais venir pourrir
les mobilisations sociales chacun voit
qu'il est voilà
celui qui dirige en sous-main même s'il
n'est plus représenté à la semaine
nationale ce qui pose d'ailleurs un
problème démocratique extrêmement
important quelqu'un qui n'est plus élu
désormais amen me semble-t-il le là de
la gauche et d'extrême gauche faudrait
rassurer toutes celles et ceux qui
s'inquiètent je l'ai dit à la première
ministre nos stress tout va bien se
passer
elle était inquiète
d'une cité même du général Darmanin
Aires qui vont vous n'êtes pas
parlementaires non mais je pourrais y
aller pourquoi je suis pas je vais
demander à mes camarades si c'est une
bonne et vous êtes le bienvenue ou pas
les parlementaires sains de leurs
écharpes seront devant l'Élysée pour
remettre une lettre de manière
solennelle au président de la République
lui demandant enfin de prendre la main
et de retirer cette réforme des
retraites la charge de l'État quand vous
êtes président de la République ou quand
vous appartenez à un gouvernement c'est
un exercice de service et ça n'est pas
un exercice de jouissance
et je pense que c'est un exercice de
jouer je pense et il lance comme ça
toutes sortes de petits
trucs de diversion alors monsieur
dussope vient dire que dire qu'il est
homosexuel donc bon très bientôt tout le
monde s'en fout elle elle va dans ce
journal et c'est une provoque pour que
vous me posiez la question moi j'ai pas
envie de perdre mon temps avec elle il y
a pas un problème à parler une fois un
journal il y a un problème quand on a le
sentiment d'avoir des gamins à l'Elysée
voilà quand on a le sentiment d'avoir
des gens qui se foutent complètement des
Français le président de la République
va dans Pif alors je suppose que il doit
y avoir Steve gadget de cette semaine
avec une petite matraque ou une grenade
lacrymogène beaucoup de monde ce matin
devant ce bureau de vote parisien
mais sur les bulletins c'est pour le
président
pas le nom du prochain président non ou
du prochain maire de Paris mais l'avenir
de la trottinette en libre-service dans
la capitale